Mi nombre es Rebecca y soy una cíborg.
(Risas)
Tengo exactamente 32 chips dentro de mi cabeza,
con los que se ha reconstruido mi sentido del oído.
Se llama "implante coclear".
¿Recuerdan los borg de Star Trek,
aquellos alienígenas que conquistaban y asimilaban a todo ser vivo?
Pues bien, eso soy yo.
(Risas)
La buena noticia es que estoy aquí por su tecnología
y no por Uds., formas de vida humana.
(Risas)
De hecho, no he visto nunca un episodio de Star Trek.
Pero hay un motivo para ello:
no había subtítulos en televisión cuando era pequeña.
Crecí con una sordera aguda.
Fui a colegios normales, donde tenía que leer los labios.
No conocí a ninguna persona sorda hasta que tuve 20 años.
Los audífonos eran mayormente equipos de sonido en aquella época.
Mi despertador era mi hermana Barbara,
que ponía su alarma y luego me lanzaba algo para despertarme.
(Risas)
Mi ayuda auditiva provenía de aparatos con volúmenes increíblemente altos,
aunque me ayudaron mucho más de lo que normalmente ayudan a otros.
Gracias a ellos, podía oír música y el sonido de mi propia voz.
Siempre me ha gustado la tecnología que hace el mundo más humano.
Solía fijarme en las barras coloreadas del volumen en mi equipo de música,
sabiendo que solo era cuestión de tiempo que mi reloj también mostrase sonidos.
¿Sabían que el acto de oír ocurre en el cerebro?
Hay un pequeño órgano en tu oreja llamado cóclea,
y la cóclea está repleta de varios miles de receptores llamados células ciliadas.
Cuando el sonido entra en tu oído,
esas células ciliadas envían señales eléctricas a tu cerebro
y éste las interpreta como sonido.
Los daños en las células ciliadas son muy comunes:
por exposición al ruido, envejecimiento, enfermedad...
Mis células ciliadas estaban dañadas incluso antes de que yo naciera.
Mi madre tuvo la rubeola cuando estaba embarazada de mí.
Alrededor del 5% de la población mundial tiene problemas serios de audición.
Se espera duplicar esta cifra en el 2050, cuando haya más de 900 millones
esto es 1 de cada 10 personas.
En personas ancianas, este valor ya es de 1 de cada 3.
Con un implante coclear,
los chips se encargan de la función de las células ciliadas deterioradas.
Imaginen una caja de 16 lápices de colores,
esos 16 lápices, al combinarse,
deben ser capaces de crear todos los colores del universo.
Lo mismo ocurre con el implante coclear.
Tengo 16 electrodos en cada una de mis cócleas.
Esos 16 electrodos se combinan y envían señales a mi cerebro,
que representan todos los sonidos presentes en el universo.
Tengo aparatos electrónicos dentro y fuera de mi cabeza
para que todo eso pueda ocurrir,
incluyendo un pequeño procesador, imanes dentro de mi cráneo
y una batería recargable.
Las ondas de radio transmiten sonido por medio de los imanes.
La pregunta principal que me suele hacer la gente sobre el implante coclear
cuando descubren que llevo imanes
es si mi cabeza se pega a la nevera.
(Risas)
No, no se pega.
(Aplausos)
Gracias, gracias.
Lo sé porque lo he probado.
(Risas)
Y escuchar a gente asumir que los sordos
vivimos con el deseo perpetuo de querer oír,
es porque no lo imaginan de otra manera...
Sin embargo, yo nunca he querido oír.
Solo quería ser parte de una comunidad de personas como yo.
Quería que todos los demás fueran sordos.
Creo que esa sensación de colectivo es la que conecta nuestras historias,
y la mía parecía incompleta.
Cuando surgieron los implantes cocleares,
en los años 80,
la operación requerida daba miedo, era como crear a Frankenstein.
En 2001, el procedimiento ya había evolucionado considerablemente,
aunque seguía eliminando posibles restos de audición natural que aún tuvieras.
Además, la tasa de comprensión oral era baja,
quizás de un 50 %.
Así que si no funcionaba, tampoco podías volver al estado de antes.
Además, en aquella época, usar implantes provocaba controversia entre los sordos.
En otras palabras, era equivalente
a cambiar el color de tu piel.
Me contuve durante un tiempo,
pero mi pérdida auditiva era rápida
y las ayudas auditivas ya no ayudaban.
Por eso, en 2003, tomé la dura decisión de colocarme un implante coclear.
Debía parar la sensación de deterioro que estaba dejándome sin fuerzas,
independientemente de si la operación funcionaba o no,
y realmente nunca creí que funcionaría.
Lo veía como una última cosa que hacer
antes de mi transición a un estado de completa sordera,
algo que una parte de mí ansiaba.
El silencio total es muy adictivo.
Quizás alguno ha estado en un tanque de aislamiento sensorial
y sabe a lo que me refiero.
El silencio tiene la capacidad de expandir tu mente.
Cuando estoy en silencio, veo el sonido.
Cuando veo un vídeo musical sin sonido,
puedo oír su música.
Si no hay sonido,
mi cerebro rellena los espacios vacíos basándose en el movimiento que percibo.
Mi mente ya no compite con la distracción que genera el sonido.
Es libre para pensar más creativamente.
Además, tener partes del cuerpo biónicas tiene sus ventajas.
No hay lugar a dudas de que oír es algo conveniente,
y puedo dejar de hacerlo cuando quiero.
(Risas)
Oigo cuando lo necesito, y el resto del tiempo no lo hago.
La audición biónica no envejece,
aunque las piezas externas necesitan recambios de vez en cuando.
Sería realmente maravilloso
si pudiéramos regenerar automáticamente una parte dañada como lo hace un cíborg,
pero el mío lo envían por FedEx desde Advanced Bionics.
(Risas)
Oh, y me actualizo
gracias a descargas en mi cabeza.
(Risas)
No es como AirDrop, pero se parece mucho.
Con el implante coclear,
puedo escuchar directamente la música de mi iPod en mi cabeza, sin auriculares.
Hace poco, fui al concierto de un amigo, largo y tedioso...
(Risas)
y sin que nadie lo supiera,
decidí escuchar, en su lugar, 3 horas de música de los Beatles.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
La tecnología ha llegado muy lejos y muy rápido.
El mayor obstáculo al que me enfrento como persona sorda
ya no es una barrera física.
Es la manera en la que la gente responde a mi sordera,
la forma desfasada con la que las personas responden a mi sordera:
pena, condescendencia, incluso enfado.
Porque todo eso anula la conexión humana
que la tecnología ha conquistado.
Una vez viajé con una persona que tenía verdaderos ataques de ira
porque no la oía al llamar a la puerta
si su llave no funcionaba.
Si no estaba ahí, no había problema, podía conseguir otra llave,
pero en cuanto veía que yo estaba dentro, su rabia se desbordaba.
Ya no tenía que ver con una llave.
Tenía que ver con el hecho de que la sordera no era motivo suficiente
para su malestar.
O aquel anuncio sobre un hombre sordo
al que su barrio sorprendía usando mensajes en lengua de signos
por parte de la gente de la calle.
Todos los que me enviaron el vídeo me dijeron que habían llorado,
así que les pregunte:
"Bueno, ¿y si no hubiera sido sordo?
¿Y si su idioma nativo fuese el español
y todos aprendiesen a hablar en español?
¿Habrías llorado?"
Y todos dijeron que no.
No lloraban por la barrera comunicativa,
lloraban porque el hombre era sordo.
Pero yo lo veo de otra manera.
¿Que ocurriría si los borg aparecieran en ese vídeo
y dijeran: "La sordera es irrelevante"?
Porque eso es lo que dicen, ¿no?
Todo es "irrelevante".
Y los borg asimilarían al sordo,
no por pena o por rabia,
sino por tener un distintivo biológico
que los borg querían,
incluyendo aptitudes únicas para comunicarse.
Me encantaría ver ese anuncio.
(Risas)
¿Por qué pensar sobre habilidades hace que la gente se sienta tan incómoda?
Puede que conozcáis una obra teatral de la que más tarde se hizo una película,
llamada "Hijos de un dios menor",
de Mark Medoff.
Esa obra, esa película,
provienen de un poema de Alfred Tennyson,
y yo entiendo que ambas expresan
que los humanos que son percibidos como defectuosos
han sido creado por un dios "menor"
y viven en un plano de existencia más bajo,
mientras que aquellos creados por el Dios real son una clase superior
porque Dios no comete fallos.
Durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
se estima que 275.000 personas con discapacidad
fueron asesinadas en campos de exterminio especiales
porque no encajaban en la visión de Hitler de una raza superior.
Hitler dijo que se había inspirado en los Estados Unidos,
que había aprobado leyes de esterilización involuntaria para los "no aptos"
a principios de la década de 1900.
Esa práctica permaneció activa en más de 30 estados hasta los años 70,
con la última de esas leyes siendo suprimida en 2003.
Parece que el mundo no tiene una idea muy diferente a la del poema de Tennyson.
Esa tendencia a asumir cosas sobre alguien basándote en sus habilidades
surge en frases como
"Eres muy especial", "yo no podría vivir con eso"
o "gracias a Dios que no he sido yo".
Cambiar la manera de pensar de la gente es como hacer que rompan un vicio.
Antes del implante, dejé de usar el teléfono de voz normal
y empecé a usar el email,
pero la gente insistía en dejarme mensajes de voz.
Les molestaba el hecho de no poder localizarme por teléfono
o de no devolverles sus mensajes.
Les expliqué mi situación muchas veces.
Les llevó meses adaptarse.
Si avanzamos 10 años,
¿saben quién odia también los mensajes de voz?
Los milenistas.
(Risas)
Y, ¿qué es lo que han hecho al respecto?
Pues en su lugar, han normalizado los mensajes para comunicarse.
Ahora, si ignoras un mensaje de voz,
ya no importa si es por ser sordo o por estar centrado en tus cosas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Los milenistas han cambiado el concepto de la gente sobre los mensajes de texto.
Han reiniciado todas las visiones.
¿Me creerían si les digo que me encanta mandar mensajes?
Oh, y mandar mensajes en grupo.
Tengo seis hermanos,
todos pueden oír
pero eso no hace que los quiera menos.
(Risas)
Y nos escribimos entre nosotros.
¿Pueden imaginar lo emocionante que es
tener un medio de comunicación visual que usa todo el mundo?
Así que ahora estoy en una misión.
Como consumidora de tecnología,
quiero tener una opción visual cuando algo tiene sonido.
No importa si es porque soy sorda
o porque no quiero despertar a mi bebé.
Ambos motivos son igualmente válidos.
Los diseñadores inteligentes
incluyen varias formas de acceder a la tecnología,
pero dificultando ese acceso por su "accesibilidad"
solo se consigue ocultarlo al usuario predominante en el mercado.
Para cambiar la forma de pensar de la gente,
no solo necesitamos ser accesibles,
necesitamos estar conectados.
Apple lo ha hecho recientemente.
En mi iPhone, ahora se muestra automáticamente una transcripción visual
de mis mensajes de voz,
junto al botón de sonido.
No podía apagarlo, ni siquiera queriendo.
¿Quieren saber más?
En Netflix, Hulu o Amazon Prime ya no pone
"subtitulado para sordos".
Pone "subtítulos". "Activados" o "desactivados",
con una lista de los idiomas justo debajo, incluyendo el inglés.
La tecnología ha llegado muy lejos.
Solo necesitamos que nuestra mentalidad avance lo suficiente para alcanzarla.
"La resistencia es fútil".
(Risas)
Han sido asimilados.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)